The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
quality educational resources
for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, welcome
to systems biology.
There are many different numbers
that you might have signed up
for this class through.
My name is Jeff Gore.
I'm an assistant professor
in the physics department.
And I think that
this is really--
it's a fun class to teach.
I hope that those of
you that stick around
for the rest of the semester
find that it's a fun class
to take as well.
I just want to give a little
bit of an introduction
of the teaching
staff, and then we'll
go over some
administrative details
before-- most of
today, what we'll do
is we'll basically
just spend an hour.
I'll give you a flash
summary of the course,
and then you'll have a
sense of the kinds of ideas
we'll be exploring.
So, what is this
thing, systems biology?
So it's, I would
say, ill-defined.
But in general, we have this
idea that, in many cases,
the really exciting functions
that we see in biology
are arising from
the interactions,
at a lower level, of
relatively simple components.
So, the kinds of behavior
that we'd like to understand
are nicely encapsulated in this
video of a neutrophil chasing
a bacterium.
And if I can-- if my computer
is actually doing something,
then-- there's something.
So, this is a classic
video that many of you
guys might have
seen over the years.
So, this was taken in the 1950s.
It's, as I said, a
neutrophil, which
is part of your
innate immune system.
So, sort of the first
line of defense.
When you get a bacterial
infection, for example,
this white blood cell is
going to chase the bacterium
and eat it up before it
can divide and harm you.
So, I'm going to
play that over again,
because it's pretty cool.
So, the features that you
want to try to pay attention
to-- so, this is
a single cell that
somehow is able to track
this bacterial invader.
It's using chemical
cues in order
to figure out where it is
that bacterial cell is going.
It's able to disregard
these red blood cells that
are in its way, push them
aside, change direction,
before it eventually
captures this bacterial cell.
So, all of these are striking,
amazing information-processing
capabilities, where
that information has
to be coupled not only to
some sort of decision-making
within that cell,
but also, it has
to be transduced into
these mechanical forces
and motions that allow that cell
to capture the bacterial cell.
So, let's try it again.
So, here it is.
You can see the
bacterial cell is here.
So, it's ignoring
this other cell,
keeping focus on this one,
pushing aside the red blood
cells, so it can
follow it along.
Every now and then-- now
the cell changed direction.
But eventually, you
can see it catches up
to the bacterial
cell and eats it.
Now you're not going to get
sick from that infection.
So, that's an example of the
kinds of remarkable behavior
that can be implemented
even just by a single cell.
So, we know that, as humans,
we have brains with 10
to the 12 neurons or so.
So, maybe you'd say,
it's not surprising
that we can do fancy things.
What's remarkable is
that even at the level
of an individual cell,
it's possible to implement
rather sophisticated information
processing capabilities.
So, this is the kind
of thing that we'd
like to be able to say something
about by the end of the class.
Many of you, I think, probably
read the course description,
and this gives you a sense
of the kinds of topics
that we're going to be
covering over the course
of the semester.
I'm not going to read it to you.
But one thing I
want to stress is
I brought up this general
idea of systems biology.
How is it that function
arises from interactions
of smaller, simpler parts?
I think it's very important,
right at the beginning,
to be clear that
there are really,
I'd say, two
distinct communities
that self-identify as
studying systems biology.
And they're-- to simplify it a
bit, what I would say is that,
basically, there's the physics,
or physics-inspired community,
where-- and I'm in the
physics department,
so that's where I fall, and
where this class is going
to be.
So, it's really trying
to use some simple models
from nonlinear dynamics
or stochastic processes
combined with
quantitative experiments,
often on single
cells, in order to try
to illuminate how this cellular
decision-making process works.
And on over the
next hour, you'll
see-- get a flavor of
what I mean by this.
Now, there's another
branch of systems biology
that is also very exciting,
and that many of you
may want to learn more
about in the future.
And maybe some of
even were thinking
that this was what the
class is going to be in.
But let me explain what is.
This other branch, I'd
say, is more influenced
by computer scientists
and engineers,
where what they're
really trying to do
is use complex models,
machine learning techniques,
and so forth, in order to
extract signal from large data
sets.
And this is also,
again, systems biology
because it is
trying to understand
how the global
properties of the cell
result from all
these interactions,
but it's a rather different
aesthetic take on the subject.
And, indeed, much
of the activity,
that one would be doing here is
different from the more physics
branch of systems biology.
So, if what you were looking
for was more of this large data
set, high throughput,
branch of systems biology,
then you may not be
at the right place.
And there's an
interesting fact, which
is that if you
decide that you want
this other branch of
systems biology, then, very
conveniently, you actually
have space in your schedule,
because Manolis
Kellis is teaching
a class in computational
biology-- really,
this other branch of systems
biology-- at the same time.
So, if you think you're
at the wrong place,
you're welcome to
just sneak out now.
Go to over 32-141, and I'm
sure that he will welcome you,
and no hard feelings.
Similarly, in the
spring, there's
another computational biology
class that some of you
may be thinking about.
And this is taught by
Chris Burge and company,
and also, I'd say, maybe
more of this other branch
of systems biology.
And, finally, once again, in
the spring there's a class,
quantitative biology
for graduate students,
that I'd say probably
assumes somewhat less
mathematical background.
So, if after looking at the
syllabus, or maybe even getting
started looking at
the first problem set,
if you think that maybe this
class is expecting too much,
then you may want to consider
taking quantitative biology
in the spring, and maybe
taking systems biology--
this class-- next fall.
So, on that note, I
want to say something
about the prerequisites.
The major challenge
with this class--
certainly, teaching
it, from my standpoint,
and I think for
many of you taking
it-- is that there's a wide
range of different backgrounds.
So, we can maybe get
a sense of that now.
Just a show of hands, how many
of you are undergraduates?
So, we've got a
solid third or so.
How many are-- mixing together
undergraduate and graduate--
but how many of you are in
the physics department at one
level or another?
So, we have maybe,
again, a third.
Biology department?
So, we have a quarter, a fifth.
Engineers?
So, a substantial
fraction of engineers.
And chemists?
We've got a few of them.
Mathematicians?
All right, we've got one.
So, if you did not raise
your hand, where you based,
physically,
intellectually, something?
Did we get everybody?
OK.
So, you can see that
there's a really broad range
of different backgrounds.
And what that means in
a concrete way for us
is that I will very
much try to avoid
using unnecessary jargon
or unnecessary mathematics.
I think that mathematics
is a wonderful thing,
but in some cases
it, I think, obscures
as much as it illuminates.
So, for me, I very
much try to focus
on conceptual understanding.
And on top of that, I try to
build-- you like math, too.
But I think that
it's very important
to be able to, for example,
plot your solution.
So, after you derive some fancy
equation describing something,
you should know
whether that thing
goes up or down as a function
of something or another.
And I think it's
very easy to lose
sight of these
basic aspects when
we get too deep into the
mathematical equations.
But, that being said, we do,
I'd say, expect something--
not necessarily
full-- you don't have
to have taken the full class,
701 or 702, but at least
a solid high school
class of biology.
If it's been more than 10 years
since you took a biology class,
you might want to take
one before coming here.
You could, in principle,
catch up, like all things.
We also assume some comfort
with differential equations
and probability.
So, we've actually added
those as prerequisites,
particularly from the
standpoint of an undergraduate
to give you a sense of
the sort of material
that we expect you to
be comfortable with.
So, we will not be defining
probably distributions so much.
We will assume that you can
calculate means and standard
deviations of discrete,
continuous distributions,
and so forth.
And the other thing that
is going to be important
is that a major
goal of the class
is to increase
your comfort level
with using computational
techniques to analyze
some of these problems.
So, every week, we're going
to have a problem set.
And on every problem set, there
will be at least one problem
where you have to use some
computational package in order
to calculate something.
So, are you going
to do a simulation
to understand the stochastic
dynamics of this or that?
Or maybe you're going to
integrate some differential
equations.
And in this case, you can use
whatever package you like.
So if you are a MATLAB
person, that's fine.
Mathematica is fine.
The officially
supported language
is going to be
Python, because that's
what Sarab-- if he's going to
be spending hours helping you
with your code, he
wants it to be something
that he's comfortable with.
So, that's going
to be what we might
call the official language, in
the sense that he will perhaps
provide some sample code and
so forth to get you started.
But you're welcome to use
anything that you want.
And that being said, we
will have a Python tutorial
almost certainly on Monday.
We're waiting to
get-- to find out what
the classroom is going to be.
But we will send out a notice
to the class about that,
as well as instructions on how
to get Python on your computer.
Are there any questions
about where we are so far?
What we've said?
Expectations, prerequisites?
All right.
So, grading.
One of the things that we have
to do is we have to grade.
I'd say that our goal is very
much to help you learn material
that we're excited about.
So, I am not in any way trying
to grade in any mean way.
And what that means
is that-- we also just
don't want you guys
to feel like you're
competing against each other.
So, what that
means is that-- so,
these are the grade cutoffs.
So, they will not-- numbers
will not go up from here.
If I screw up and I make
some really hard exam,
then I reserve the right
to lower these numbers.
But basically, this
is what's worked
for the last several years.
So, you should feel comfortable
collaborating with your friends
to study, to try to
figure out the material,
because your grade
is just going to be
determined by where things end
up on this chart, basically.
And the course grade is going
to be split, as you can see.
There's a fair component
on problem sets,
and that's because
the problem sets are--
they're going to be hard work.
We're going to have
problem sets every week,
and you can expect to spend
a significant amount of time
on them.
And the thing that
you learn in doing
these computational
problems is somewhat
different from what
you learn and what
you demonstrate on an exam.
So, that's why it's not
all just an exam grade.
I'm going to say something more
about these pre-class reading
questions.
There are going to be
two midterms and an exam.
The dates are on your syllabus,
so please mark these evenings
on your calendar.
So, the problem sets.
You can read about this.
But basically, every
Friday at 7 o'clock,
they're going to be due.
A box out between the
third floor of building six
and the fourth floor
of building 16,
I suppose-- these are the
physics homework boxes.
So, the idea is we'd like
you to have a weekend
to catch up and start
reading for the next week.
So, that's why they're dude
just before dinner on Friday.
That being said, we understand
that sometimes there
are a lot of problem sets, or
sometimes you're overwhelmed
with something else.
So, that's fine.
You can turn it
in for 80% credit
till Monday morning at
10:00 AM, when we're
going to post the solutions.
So, we won't be accepting
problem sets after that,
unless you get agreement
from Sarab in advance.
So, the pre-class
reading questions.
I'd say this is a key
part of the class.
It's only 5% of
the grade, and it's
graded really only
on participation--
that you've done it.
But this is an essential
element of what we like
to call a flipped classroom.
So, today's class is
going to be rather
different from the rest of the
semester in that today is more
like a lecture, I would say.
Whereas the rest
of the semester,
there will not be any PowerPoint
slides and it'll be very much,
I hope, very interactive.
In order to
facilitate that, there
are a number of
different elements.
One is that we do require
reading before class.
And the way that we encourage
you to do the reading
is that we ask you to answer
questions the night before.
So, what you're going
to do is you'll,
by 10:00 PM, the night before,
just three questions-- just
a couple of sentences
each question.
It's not that you're supposed
to have to do a lot of work.
It's just that if
you did the reading,
you should be able to
give your take on it,
and you think about
it a little bit.
And then Andrew will go
over the submitted answers,
and we'll send out his favorite
answers among the group.
So, your answer
will occasionally
be represented there, if you
say something that's reasonable.
Now, it's really important
to have done this reading
and thought about the
material some before,
because the idea is that,
in class, we'd really
like to engage in what you
might call some higher level
learning.
So, it's not just this idea
that-- the traditional lecture
arose when books
were very expensive.
So, if you're at a university
in the 13th century,
you don't have a textbook.
So, what you need is for me to
stand up front and read to you.
And that's fine, except that
it's better for you to read it.
And you can read it outside of
class, think about it a bit.
And then that means
when you come to class,
we can actually discuss it.
In particular, I'll
give you my take
on the material, the
research that I'm
excited about in the area
that's been published recently.
And we will also try to get
you involved via these concept
questions.
So, in future sessions we'll
have these flash cards,
or these colored
cards, so we can
ask these conceptual questions.
A, B, C, D-- if you drop an
apple, does it go up, down,
left, right?
And then, you guys get to vote.
And then, after the vote, we
will often have you pair up.
And the goal there
is that you're
trying to convince your
neighbor that you're right.
And after that, you might
expand it to fours or so.
But the idea there is that
it's very important for you
to try to confront the
material, make your best guess,
and then discuss
it with a neighbor.
And I think that
this is actually
one of the fun
aspects of the course.
At least, I think so.
And I'll say also that
this basic technique
is the result of-- there's
a whole field of education
research.
And there are very,
very consistent
and strong signals
in this, suggesting
that this sort of flipped
classroom, active learning
style, actually is
good for learning.
So I'm not just doing this
because-- it is more fun,
but that's not actually
why I'm doing it.
I'm doing it because
the people who
have spent their lives
studying this topic
have included this is
the best way to teach.
Any questions about
the pre-class questions
or my notion of active learning?
All right.
You can mark your
calendars in advance.
We do have a final.
It has not been scheduled yet.
It'll be sometime the
week of December 15-19.
So, for those of
you who are looking
online for plane tickets
back home, after December 19.
Or, if you'd like, you
can wait a couple weeks,
and then the final
will be scheduled.
We have two required
textbooks for the class.
The first is An Introduction
to Systems Biology by Uri Alon.
I think it's a wonderfully
clear, exciting introduction
to the topic.
The flip side of being
wonderfully clear
is that it's a
little-- you could
complain that it's too simple.
And what that means is that we
will be supplementing the book
in a variety of ways,
both with separate notes,
and also by extensive
reading of papers
from the primary literature.
The second half or
third of the class,
we'll be reading some chapters
from Evolutionary Dynamics,
a book by Martin Nowak.
Again, a very nice, I think,
clear, exciting introduction
to that field.
So, I think that
these are both books
that, if you're at all
interested in this area,
you should own anyways.
There are two other
books that you
might want to recommend buying.
So, first there's
Essential Cell Biology,
which is kind of like the
easy version of the cell, also
by Alberts.
So, be careful of just
buying a book by Alberts.
So, I'd say The Cell
is everything you ever
wanted to know about
the cell-- and more
than you want to
know about the cell--
whereas Essential
Cell Biology is really
just a wonderful book.
We read this in my lab as
kind of a summer book reading
project, where each
week, we read a chapter,
and we got get over lunch.
And we just went
around the table,
and we went through all the
questions in the book-- really.
And we just alternated, and we
discussed, and it was-- really,
it's wonderful.
It focuses on the ideas.
You have to memorize
a few things.
But every now and then, you
need to memorize something
in order to keep track
of what's going on.
But I would say that if you're
really interested in biology
in any serious way, then I would
recommend you buy this book.
And then, finally, there's
this book Nonlinear Dynamics
and Chaos by Steven
Strogatz, which
is a beautiful introduction
to denominator dynamics.
If you have not seen the book,
I encourage you to check it out.
And in particular, some of the
topics on stability analysis,
and oscillations, bifurcations,
and so forth-- this
is a really great way
to learn about them.
I want to just give a
brief plug for-- there's
another class that some of
you, especially the first year
students interested
in biophysics,
might be interested in.
This is 8.590J slash 20.416J
slash seven something.
So it's a class targeted for
first year graduate students
interested in biophysics.
Basically, each week,
we read a paper.
We have a different
guest lecturer
come from across campus, either
physics, chemistry, biology,
biological engineering, civil
or environmental engineering.
So, a great way to meet
different faculty who
are working in the interface
of physics and biology
in one manifestation or another.
The class-- it's going to be
this Friday from 3:00 to 5:00
PM.
But then, in later
weeks, it's going
to be 4:00 to 6:00 PM because
we-- because it conflicted
with something.
So, I'm going to tell
you-- I'm going to give you
the overview of the rest
of the semester in terms
of the science.
But I just want to
first remind all of you
that, starting on Tuesday, it's
going to be the real class.
What that means in
particular is that we
expect you to have
done some reading,
and we expect you
to have submitted
your pre-class reading questions
by Monday night at 10:00 PM.
We used to have it at
midnight, but then Andrew
has to stay up really late
to go over all your responses
and send out them--
so, 10 o'clock.
And then we'll get going
on simple interactions
between doing enzyme and
substrate, simple gene
expression ideas, and so forth.
So, I'd say that the
course has three parts.
There's like-- the
first half is part one,
and then part two is
the half to 3/4 mark,
and then the last part is
maybe four or five lectures.
And the structure
of this is really--
it is going from the
microscopic scale,
and then-- in terms of
just the basic ideas of,
what happens if molecule A
binds with molecule B. What
are the features that
we should be aware of?
So, pretty basic there.
All the way up to
questions in ecology.
The last lecture is going to
be questions about the origin
of diversity in ecosystems.
So, we'll basically march
from the molecular scale
up to the population scale
throughout the semester.
For those of you who are
interested in thinking
about these questions of
how to organize a class,
there's quite an
interesting discussion
at the beginning of Bill
Bialek's Biological Physics
book, where he very
explicitly says
that he tried to resist
the temptation to do what
it is that we do in our class.
He resisted the temptation
to start from the small scale
and then build up to
these larger scales.
And the reason he
says he wants to avoid
that is because he does not want
to give students the impression
we actually understand how
you go from the lower scales
up to the higher scales.
And I think that's a totally
reasonable viewpoint.
But that being said, the whole
point of this endeavour is
to try to say
something about it.
We may not really understand
it all, but we have to try.
And it's certainly true that is
how function arises, that there
are lower level interactions
that lead to higher scale
functions, dynamics, behaviors.
We may not be able to predict
exactly what's going on there,
but that is the way
that nature does it.
So, I don't want a second
guess nature, certainly.
So, that's going
to be our approach.
But if at the end of the class,
you prefer a different order,
you can always just
turn yourself around,
and then it all jumble
up in your brain.
And then, it can be
whatever order you like.
On Tuesday, we're
really going to start
with the most basic ideas.
What happens if you
have, for example,
one gene that is going
to turn on another gene?
So, you might have a
transcription factor
X that's going to
activate so gene Y, that
says it's going to cause
gene Y to be expressed.
Now, it's as simple
as you can get.
But what are the
general features
that you can say about
this sort of process?
Well, you can say,
there's one thing.
It's that X could either
be an activator of Y,
or maybe it's a
repressor of Y. So,
these are the two symbols
that we'll often use.
An arrow will
either be an-- well,
this symbol will
always be a repressor.
A plain arrow may be
ambiguous, so beware.
Now, the question is,
what happens here?
For example, you might have
this transcription factor--
let's say 10R-- that's
repressing expression
of this gene that is encoding
GFP, green fluorescent protein.
You're going to see this many,
many times over the course
of the semester.
In some ways, one of
the things that we're
going to see in the class
is that new ideas often
arise from new techniques
or new capabilities.
Now, it was really, I think,
the Y-- the spread of GFP
and related proteins that
allowed us to visualize gene
expression in individual cells.
And it led to this real
flowering of new ideas,
of how, for example,
stochasticity may be relevant,
cell to cell heterogeneity.
These are all, I think,
very interesting ideas.
But in order for them to
be concrete, you need data.
And this was a
powerful way for us
to get data that was
relevant for these sorts
of big questions.
So, the idea here is that
if this protein is made,
it's expressed.
Then that cell will
become fluorescent.
In particular,
it'll become green
if you shine the
proper light on it.
And then, we can do things.
We can ask questions
about, for example,
the dynamics of this process.
So, here we have a
case where, now, this
is a repressor that is--
if you have this repressor,
then it stops expression of
that fluorescent protein.
Now, you can ask, what happens
if you start in a situation
where the cell is repressing
expression of that gene.
So, in this case, the
protein concentration is 0,
so the cell is not fluorescent.
But then, you add
something so that now you
cause that repressor to fall off
and stop repressing that gene.
Now, the question
is, how long does it
take for the protein
concentration
to grow to some equilibrium?
It starts out at 0.
Eventually, it's going to
reach some steady state.
So, what is it that
sets this time scale?
What's the characteristic time
that it takes for the cell
to respond to this signal?
What we're going to
find is that there's
a very general sense in which
that characteristic time
scale is really the
cell generation time.
So, cells divide at some rate.
It depends on the kind of cell,
the environment, and so forth.
Does anybody have a sense
for a bacterial cell
in nice, rich media, good
temperature-- how long it
takes for it to divide?
Yeah, 20 minutes.
So, E. coli, for example,
can divide every 20 minutes,
if you put it in the
right environment.
Which is really
an amazing thing,
if you think about the
number of different proteins
that have to be made, and
the complicated mechanics
of growing, and
separating, and so forth.
But every 20 minutes
such a cell can divide.
That's saying that a
bacterial cell, when
it sees a new signal,
it's going to take,
of order, that amount of time
in order for it to do anything.
And that's just because of this
natural process of dilution.
So, as the cell grows, there's
a dilution of the contents.
So, it makes sense.
If you start out with a
protein and you stop making it,
then maybe you'll get
an exponential decay
of that concentration with this
time scale, the cell generation
time.
What's interesting is
that, in some ways,
that resolve is more general.
That, even if you're trying
to turn something on,
there's the same limit,
this cell generation time,
that is placing some limit to
how fast the cell can respond
to new information, if it
uses this mode of information
transmission where you
express a new gene.
So, if you want
to go faster, than
you have to do something else.
So, in some cases,
you can actually
have a situation where a protein
is actually regulating itself.
So, this is an example
of what you might
call negative autoregulation.
So, in this case, that
protein actually comes back,
and it represses
its own expression.
It's found that this is actually
rather common in biology.
And so, of course,
if you see something
that is common in biology,
then it's reasonable that-- so,
maybe there's an
evolutionary explanation.
Not always, but it
gives you a hint
that maybe it's worth looking.
Now, in this case, what
we're going to find
is that such negative
autoregulation does
some very interesting things.
So, for example, one thing
that it's been shown to do
is to increase the rate
of response of that gene.
So, in some ways, you can speed
up a response to some signal
by having that negative
autoregulation.
In a similar way, this
negative autoregulation
increases what you
might call robustness,
the ability of the
function-- in this case,
maybe, the concentration--
of the protein
to be robust to variations in
things like the temperature,
or this or that.
So, environmental
perturbations, or maybe
just stochastic fluctuations.
Now, in this field, I'd say
one of the key advances that
led to the birth of both this
branch of systems biology,
but also the field of what you
might call synthetic biology--
really using engineering
principles to try and design
new gene circuits-- was a
pair of important papers
that we're going to be
talking about in this class.
So, the first of these was a
paper from Jim Collins's group.
He was at BU, although you
may not have heard yet,
but he's actually just agreed
to move over here at MIT.
So, this is very exciting for
us, and hopefully for you.
So, Jim Collins--
in 2000 he showed
that he could engineer
a switch, something
called a toggle switch.
So, if you have two genes
that are mutually repressing
each other, then
this is a system
that the most basic
memory module.
Because if you have
one gene that's high,
it can repress the other one,
and that's a stable state.
But if this other
gene goes high,
then it's going to
repress this one here,
and that's another stable state.
And that state,
since it's stable,
can maintain memory of
the past environment.
And he was able to
demonstrate to his group
that he could construct such
a switch using components
that, in the past, were never
interacting with each other.
So, this is taking advantage
of this fabulous modularity
of the components
of biology in order
to do something that,
is in, principle useful.
And by doing this, it's possible
that you could go and engineer
new things.
But it's also a test bed
for you to take this dictum
from Feynman that if
you can't build it,
then you don't understand it.
And this is a nice way
to go into the cell
and say, if it's really
true, if all these models
that we talk about in systems
biology, for example--
if they're really true,
then we should actually
be able to go into the cell,
put these components together,
and demonstrate that
there is, for example,
this switch-like behavior.
And this was a very
important paper
that demonstrated that
it's possible to do this.
The other paper that I think--
AUDIENCE: Did they
actually make the switch?
PROFESSOR: Yes They
actually constructed it.
They put it on a round, circular
piece like this plasmid,
put it into E. coli, and showed
that they could do this here.
And indeed, this particular
issue of nature, I think,
was hugely influential
for our field,
because that toggle switch
paper and this other paper--
"The Repressilator," by Michael
Elowitz and colleagues--
they were kind of back to
back in that issue of nature.
And I'd say, in some ways, they
were the beginning of systems
and synthetic biology.
Of course, you can
argue about this.
But certainly, I
think they influenced
many, many people in getting
excited about the field.
So, the repressilator--
this is the idea
that you can generate
a gene circuit
like this that will oscillate.
And in this case, instead of
having just two genes that
are repressing each
other, if instead you
have three genes that are
repressing each other,
but in a circular
fashion, then there's
no stable state akin to what we
have with this toggle switch.
But instead, what
happens is that you
get successive waves of each
of these components going
up and down.
So, they oscillate as they
mutually repress each other.
And I just want to be
clear about what this is.
So, here, these
are E. coli cells,
where Elowitz put
in this plasmid--
this circular piece of
DNA-- encoding those three
genes that mutually
repress each other.
And basically, associated
with one of those genes,
he's again attached one of
these fluorescent proteins.
So, the level of
fluorescence in the cell
tells you about the state
of that gene circuit.
Let's see if we can--
So, it starts out.
There's a single cell
you can't really see.
It starts dividing.
Then you see it oscillates--
gets bright, dim, bright, dim.
But you can see that there
are a number of features you
might notice about this movie.
So, first, it does oscillate,
which was huge in the sense
that it wasn't obvious
that you could actually
just put these genes together
and generate something
that oscillates at all.
On the other hand,
you'd say, well
it's not such a good oscillator.
In particular, for example, this
started out as a single cell.
Now it's dividing under
the microscope on agger.
So, it's getting
some nutrients there.
But what you see is
that-- are these cells
all in phase with each other?
No.
So, there's patches--
bright, dark.
So, the question is,
what's going on here?
And it turns out that this
design of an oscillator
is perhaps not a very good one.
And, indeed, one of things
we'll be talking about
is how you can maybe use
some engineering principles
to design better oscillators.
So, for example, Jeff
Hasty at San Diego
has done really
beautiful work showing
that you can make robust,
tunable oscillators in cells
like this.
Now, these oscillations
they were maybe not as good
as you would like.
But this, actually,
is an example
of how a partial failure--
in the sense that they're not
great oscillations,
that maybe somehow
there's noise that's entering
in here that you would not like.
This led to the realization
that maybe noise
is relevant in decision
making within cells.
And this led-- I'll show
you in a few slides--
to another major advance
that Elowitz had.
So, this is, I
think, a good example
of how one-- we might
call it a partial failure.
Some reservations about the
quality of this oscillator
led him to another really
big scientific discovery
on the importance of noise in
decision making within cells.
But before we get
to this noise, we're
going to say something about
the more global structure
of these gene networks.
And, in particular,
we're going to analyze,
and we're going to read
this paper by Barabasi which
represents a simple
mechanism for how you might
what are called these power-law
distributions in networks.
So, if you have these
genes that are mutually
activating-repressing,
what can you
say about the structure of this
gene network within the cell?
Now, you can analyze
such global structure
in a couple of different ways.
One is just to ask, how
many different genes are
different genes connected to?
And that's maybe the
more Barabasi approach.
But then there was
another major discovery
that Uri Alon, the author
of our textbook, made,
which is that you can
ask-- in this crazy network
that you have that describes
the decision making
within the cell-- are
there common patterns
or motifs that appear
over and over again?
So, just like this
idea of autoregulation,
when a gene represses
or activates itself,
that's something that
appears frequently.
So, you can ask,
why might that be?
Similarly, if there
are other patterns that
appear in these networks,
then maybe they arose,
or they were selected for
by evolution, because they
perform some other function.
In particular, we're going to
analyze this feed-forward loop
motif, where you have some gene
that activates, for example,
another gene Y. Y
activates-- I'm sorry,
this is supposed to be Z. Now,
if X, again, directly activates
or represses Z-- this
bottom gene-- then
what does that do for you?
Because this is something
you see more frequently
than you expect, based
on some notion of chance,
or some null model.
So, the question is, why
would these feed-forward loops
appear over and over again?
And it turns out that they can
provide some nice functions
in the sense that,
for example, you
can provide some
asymmetrical response
to temporary fluctuations of
inputs, et cetera, et cetera.
So, we'll try to get some
sense of these ideas.
So, as I alluded to before in
this idea of the repressilator
that Michael
Elowitz made, he saw
that it was surprisingly noisy.
And this got him
thinking about the role
of stochastic
fluctuations within cells.
And I think that this is a
common theme throughout much
of systems biology.
It's the role of
noise in biology.
And this could be within a cell
for individual decision making.
It could be in context
of development--
how is that you robustly
make a body, given noise?
It could be at the level
of evolutionary ecosystems,
that maybe noise actually
plays a dominant role in,
for example, determining
the abundance
or diversity of ecosystems.
So, we'll see these themes
pop up on multiple scales
throughout the semester.
But in this case,
what Elowitz did--
this is just two years after
his repressilator paper--
he showed that if you just
take the-- in a single cell,
you give it the exact
same instructions.
So, you say, make a red
fluorescent protein,
and make a green
with the exact same
instructions to the cell.
And you can say, well, if you
have the same instructions,
then the level of
the red and the green
should do the same thing.
But what he found
was that, actually,
there was surprising
heterogeneity
of the level of those two
proteins, even in single cells.
So, the idea is that even-- this
represents a fundamental limit
to what a cell can
do, because this
is saying that we take-- we try
to do the exact same thing two
different times.
If you don't get
the same output,
then that's a real limit
to what you can do, right?
Because you've done
everything you can.
You said, here's the
sequence of that DNA that has
the instructions, this
promoter sequence.
It's exactly the same, yet you
still get different outputs.
So, the question is,
what's causing that?
And also, how is it
that life can actually
function given this intrinsic
noise that's in the cell?
These are things
that we're going
to look at over the
course of the semester.
And these are
actually some images
that he took in this paper.
And so, we can see
that some of the cells
are really rather red.
Some are rather yellowish green.
And so, this is telling us about
the level of those proteins
in individual cells.
So now, we have some notion.
So, somehow, noise is important
in these molecular scale gene
expression patterns.
Now, there is what I think is
really quite a beautiful paper
by Sunney Xie [INAUDIBLE]
at Harvard in 2006,
where he combined
a single molecule
fluorescence with live
cell imaging in E. coli.
And this allowed him to observe
individual expression events
within individual
cells, where every time
one of these proteins
was expressed,
he got a little yellow
spot, corresponding
to this equivalent of a
yellow fluorescent protein.
And so, he was able to watch
as real, live cells made
individual proteins.
And from that, he was
able to say, I think,
some very nice things about
what it is that's causing noise,
such as what we talked
about in that repressilator,
or in the other Elowitz paper.
And a lot of it just
has to with this idea
that if you're talking about
low number events or low numbers
of molecules-- DNA
typically present, only
one or a few copies
per cell-- then
that means there's some
inherent stochasticity.
Because that piece
of DNA-- it's either
bound by one of these motors,
this RNA polymerase that
can make the RNA, or not.
And that is intrinsically going
to be a stochastic process.
And that kind of
dynamic can lead
to substantial heterogeneity,
or fluctuations,
in expression of
individual genes.
So, it's kind of at
this stage of the course
that we start to think
maybe a little bit more
about some of the global
aspects of what it
is that a cell is trying to do.
And in particular, if
a cell is trying to,
for example, swim to get to
higher concentrations of food,
what are the fundamental
limitations that cell faces?
How does it know what is
uphill, what's downhill?
So, these are cases in which
we have to really understand
something about the
role of diffusion
in the ability of
these small cells
to move in their environment.
And for example, here
is an illustration
of the Reynolds number, which
is telling you something
about the relative
importance of viscous forces
versus inertial forces on
these different organisms.
And some of the
way-- for example,
how an organism
such as us can swim
is just qualitatively
different from how
a microscopic organism,
such as E. coli, can swim.
So we'll try to understand
how that plays out
and, in particular, how it
is that E. coli can move
towards higher food sources.
And there's a very
clever way that bacteria
have that allows
them to have really
robust functioning of
this chemotaxis process
within the cell.
And I think this is a neat
example of the gene networks
coupling into a higher
level behavior that
allows cells to
survive in really
challenging environments.
Another manifestation,
actually, of fluctuations
is this idea of
pattern formation.
And this is actually
experimental data of in vitro--
so, if you take proteins
outside of the cell
and you put them on a
two dimensional membrane.
Now, these are
actually the proteins
that are responsible for
finding the center of the cell.
So, I told that E. coli, for
example-- it grows in length.
And then, once it gets long
enough, it wants to divide,
so it separates in the middle.
And the question is, how does
it know where the middle is?
You know, if you can just stand
outside a cell and look at it,
then you say, I know where
it is, and you just cut.
But imagine you're a cell.
How do you know
where this-- once you
start thinking about all these
challenges that cells face,
it's really remarkable
that they can do anything.
And what it turns out,
is that they implement--
they use what are called these
Min proteins that display what
seem to be the equivalent
of what you might know
of as Turing patterns
in order to cause
these oscillations in the cell
that allows it to find where
the center of the cell is.
So, we'll talk about this
and how these authors were
able to visualize these
beautiful traveling
waves of proteins, where
they successfully bind
to the membrane, and then
are ejected off of it.
And this results in
beautiful patterns
that are traveling, as you saw.
So, this was-- I'd say that
these topics are what you might
call traditional
systems biology,
in the sense that these
are all things that
of physics branch
of systems biology
were all thinking about
for the first 10 years.
And over the last five
years, maybe, there
has been a greater
interest in trying
to understand how these
sorts of ideas and principles
may be relevant
for larger scale.
And larger the sense of,
instead of thinking maybe
about genes as this
fundamental unit--
they try to understand
how genes interact to form
this decision making process.
Maybe instead, if
you think about cells
as somehow being that
fundamental unit,
how is it that
cells come together
to lead to interesting
population level phenomena?
And so, we talk about
both what you might call
evolutionary systems biology.
So, how is it that evolution
within a population behaves?
As well as ecological
systems biology.
What happens if you have
more than one species,
and how is that
the kinds of ideas
we talk about in the
first half of the semester
are relevant in these
population level phenomena?
So, in the first example
that we're going to give
is actually another paper
from Uri Alon's group,
where he showed that there's a
very fundamental sense in which
cells, through the
evolutionary process,
are implementing a
cost-benefit analysis.
And the question
that he asked here
is that, if you
take an E. coli cell
and you put it in different
concentrations of the sugar
lactose.
Now, the question is,
how much of the enzyme
responsible for digesting
lactose-- how much of that
enzyme should you make?
You might say, well, you
should just make a lot of it.
But he said, well,
at some point,
there's going to be a problem.
Because if you make
too much of it,
then you're going to be
spending all of your energies
making this enzyme.
Whereas, on the other hand,
if you don't make enough,
then you're not going to be able
to get enough of this sugar.
So, like always, there's
this Goldilocks principle.
You don't want too little;
you don't want too much.
And what he showed is that
if he evolved these E. coli
populations over hundreds of
generations in the laboratory,
but at different concentrations
of this sugar lactose, what
he saw is that the
concentration, or the level
of expression of the enzymes
required to make that,
to break down that sugar--
it changes over time.
So, if you have a
lot of the sugar,
then you want to make
a lot of the enzyme.
If you have a small
amount of that sugar,
then you want to make
less of the enzyme.
So, that all makes sense.
But this is a case where he
could really demonstrate it
in the laboratory using
these microbial populations.
It's a very beautiful
example of how
simple ideas of
cost-benefit really
give you insight into
the evolutionary process.
Now, I told you before
that part of the reason
that we have to consider the
role of fluctuations, or noise,
in, for example,
cellular decision making,
is because of the low
numbers of molecules
that are often involved.
So, if you have a small
number of proteins,
or small numbers of
DNA, then the process
is intrinsically stochastic.
Now, the question
naturally arises,
why is it that we might need
to consider stochastic dynamics
in the context of evolution?
Because if you think
about, for example,
an E. Coli population,
even in a small test tube,
you might have 1
billion cells there.
So, 1 billion is a
big number, right?
Much larger than 1.
So, it's tempting to conclude
from that, that actually, all
of this stochastic dynamics,
fluctuations-- maybe it's just
not relevant for evolution.
However, if you think about
the evolutionary process,
fundamentally, any time that
you have a new mutant appear
in the population that may be
more fit, may be less fit--
but every new mutant
in the population
starts out as a
single individual.
It's a trivial statement,
but it has deep implications,
because it means that every
evolutionary process goes
through this regime
where you have
a small number of fluctuations.
So, this has very
clear locations
in many different
contexts, and we'll
explore it over the
course of the semester.
And despite the fact that that
evolution is intrinsically,
you might say, random,
what's interesting
are cases where that
randomness somehow washes out.
For example, we're
going to talk about what
I think is a beautiful paper
by Roy Kishony's group,
at Harvard Medical
School, who showed
that if you take a
population and you put
in some new
environments, there are
going to different mutations.
Some of them are going to
be really good; some of them
are going to be not so good.
You can imagine that of all
of these possible beneficial
mutations, they describe
some distribution.
Whereas, if you asked-- this is
the frequency, or the number,
of mutations as a function
of how good that mutation is,
you might say, it should
be some falling function.
Because you just not are
going to get as many mutations
that are really just
amazing as they are.
They're kind of good.
But it's not obvious whether
the curve should be exponential,
or maybe it looks like this.
It could look like
many different things.
What Roy's group showed
here in this paper is that,
actually, in some very
reasonable situations,
it doesn't actually matter what
the underlying distribution
might be.
Because if you look at the
distribution of mutations that
actually fix or spread
in the population,
those actually all
look kind of the same,
in the sense that they're
peaked around some value.
So, there's some sense in which
the random process of evolution
leads to some patterns that
are probably not so obvious.
And on the flip
side, what it means
is that if you go and measure
how good are the mutations that
actually appear
on the population,
that actually tells you
surprisingly little about what
that underlying distribution
is, in terms of the effects
of the beneficial mutations.
So, there's some way in which
the details kind of wash out.
And I think this is fascinating
because a major theme
or major challenge
in systems biology
is we want understand how
these underlying parts lead
to some higher level
function, but we don't always
know which details
of the interactions
are important for
leading to that higher
level of organization.
In some cases, they're very
important, but in some cases,
not.
So, a challenge that we're going
to face over and over again
is trying to understand, what
are the key features that
are going to influence the
dynamics of this higher level
system?
And this is, I think,
an interesting example
of how some features of
that underlying distribution
are important, and some are not.
So, another interesting
analogy between evolution
and some ideas from
physics is this idea
of a fitness landscape.
So, just like an
energy landscape
tells you something
about the dynamics
of a system-- for
example, you can say,
a ball should roll down a hill.
Similarly, if you
think about evolution
in the context of how
fit an organism is
as a function of some
different parameters,
you can get what might
be nontrivial structure.
So, this is some illustration
of what's perhaps
a nontrivial fitness landscape.
Now, the height here is
some notion of fitness.
So, we could imagine
this could be
the ability of a bird to fly.
In that case, maybe
these two axes
could be the length and
the width of the wing.
Now, the shape of this
landscape tells you
something about how
evolution is constrained.
Because if the landscape
looks like this,
then what that's saying is
that you have to actually
evolve, in this case,
maybe a wider wing
before you can
evolve a longer wing.
So, this is-- if there's
structure to the fitness
landscape like this, then
it tells you something
about the path of evolution.
Now, in this case,
we're thinking
about this in the context
of phenotypes-- things
that you can just look at
the organism and measure.
But instead of think about
this in terms of phenotypes,
we could instead think of
it in terms of genotype.
For example, there
is a beautiful paper
that we're going to read
from Daniel Weinreich
where he, in the context
of a gene that encodes
an enzyme that breaks down
antibiotics such as penicillin,
what he did is he made
all possible combinations
of five point mutations--
single limitations in the gene.
So, he made all 32
combinations of this gene
and then measured the shape of
the resulting fitness landscape
from those 32 different
versions of the gene.
And from it, what he
found is that there's
a very interesting sense
in which evolution,
at the molecular scale,
is somehow constrained.
So, the idea there
is that there somehow
is a rugged fitness landscape
that is constraining
the path of evolution.
And so, in all these cases
that we've been talking about,
there's some notion
that you can say,
this organism has
this fitness so long
as it has a wing shape
that looks like this.
Now, that is perhaps
find in many cases.
But in some cases,
there are what
you might call game interactions
between different organisms
in a population.
And what I mean by
game interactions
is that the fitness of
a particular organism
may depend upon what other
organisms are out there.
And in that case,
you can't just say
that one organism is fit or
not, because it just depends
on what everyone else in
the population is doing,
or the genotype of the other
individuals in the population.
So, in that case,
you really have
to apply some ideas
from game theory
to try to get insight into
the evolutionary process.
And we're going to talk
about some really nice cases
where researchers have
constructed, for example,
a rock, paper, scissors
game using different E. coli
strains.
And if you stick
out to that long,
I'll tell you about
a case in lizards
where people have
demonstrated a rock, paper,
scissors interaction in the
context of different mating
strategies of the male lizards.
So, if that's not
an advertisement
to stick around for a couple
months, I don't know what is.
There are other cases where
people have demonstrated
that microbes interact via
cooperative interactions,
in which it's possible
for cheater strategies
to arise, spread
throughout the population,
and cause some harm
to the population--
maybe even collapse
of the population.
So, this is a case
where there's tension
between what's good
for the individual
and what's good for the group.
Now, organisms are able to do
a remarkable set of things.
So, we saw cases where, for
example, that neutrophil
was able to chase the staph
aureus, that bacterial cell.
So, that's amazing.
But that's responding
to something
that is an immediate
part of the environment.
So, it's chasing
a bacterial cell.
But you might ask, is it
possible for cells to learn?
And, of course, then
you have to define
what you mean by learning.
And there's been some really
interesting demonstrations
of how it's possible
for organisms
to learn not at the
individual level, necessarily,
but at the population
level, via evolution.
And in particular, in this
very well written paper,
what they were
able to demonstrate
is that both yeast that have
evolved in the context of wine
fermentation and E. coli that
have evolved traveling through,
for example, our
digestive tracts,
there are characteristics,
sequences of events,
in which things happen.
So, the idea is that if a
bacterial cell is ingested
by a mammal, they will typically
see one carbon source, and then
another one.
So, they might see carbon source
A, and then carbon source B,
as they travel through
the digestive tract.
But if that is typically
what happens, then
what it means is that
an organism might have
an advantage if, when
it sees carbon source A,
it starts preparing to
digest carbon source B. So,
we can actually learn something
about typical environmental
orderings.
But it's not learning at
the individual cell level.
It's learning over the course
of evolutionary time scales,
the typical sequence of events.
And in this paper,
they show that this
seems to be the case
for both E. coli
and for yeast in the
context of fermentation.
So, I think it's a
really beautiful example
of different notions of what
you might mean by learning.
So, another classic
debate within the field
of evolutionary is this
question of, why sex?
And in particular, there's
this classic paradox
which is saying, sex is costly.
In particular, if you
take a bacterial cell,
just one cell turns
into two cells.
And then two can turn
into four, and you
get very rapid exponential
growth of the population.
Whereas, if you have
both males and females,
then there's what you might
call this twofold cost of sex.
Because males are,
in some sense,
not contributing to that
exponential growth rate.
If you start with a male,
female, and they have two kids,
and you have another
male, female, and then
you don't get
exponential growth.
And this is a factor of 2 in
the rate of exponential growth.
So this is what's
in that exponent.
So, this is a big, big effect.
And so, I think it's a
major, major challenge
to ask, why is it that sex is
so common among what you might
call the higher organisms.
And there are many hypotheses.
We'll talk about some of them.
One of the leading ones is known
as the Red Queen hypothesis
from this Lewis Carroll story,
where there's this line.
The Red Queen has to run
faster and faster in order
to keep still where she is.
That is exactly what
you all are doing.
And the reason that it's
called the Red Queen hypothesis
is because it's arguing that
perhaps the reason that we
and other animals have
obligate sexual reproduction
is because of some arms
race with parasites--
that the sexual
reproduction allows
us to evolve more rapidly
against the always
adapting parasite populations.
And of course,
we'll have to talk
about exactly what this means.
But there have been some
interesting experiments
in worms, in which they
had different reproductive,
different sexual
strategies, in the presence
or absence of parasites.
And this showed that there are
some interesting cases where
this may be at least
part of what's going on.
So, at this stage,
we've been talking first
about decision
making within cells,
and then how evolution may
allow cells to anticipate
different environmental
changes, may
be able to play games
against other strategies.
But at the end, we're
just going to talk
some about inter-species
interactions,
and what these sorts
of ideas may be
able to say about that process.
So, for example, a classic
inter-species interaction
are predator-prey interactions.
And this has been
used to explain,
for example, why it is that many
natural populations oscillate
over time.
There are simple
models of a predator
and prey that lead
to such oscillations.
And just over the
last 10 years, there
have been some really
fascinating experiments where,
in the laboratory, they were
able to take predator-prey,
show that they oscillate.
But then, in this case,
they saw some features
that they weren't expecting.
The oscillations were
maybe much longer
than they were anticipating.
And instead of
oscillating 90 degrees out
of phase-- which
is what you expect
from standard predator-prey
models-- instead
they were oscillating
180 degrees out of phase.
And I think that this
is a good example of how
quantitative experiments
in the laboratory
can actually say something
about the classic models
of predator-prey oscillations.
They are over 100 years old.
But if you go, and you make
quantitative measurements
in the lab, you see,
actually, in many cases,
things are different.
And then, you can ask, why?
In this case, they
went-- they did modeling,
and they said, maybe
it's because of evolution
within the prey population.
And once they were
able to-- they
had hypothesized
that from modeling.
And then they went, and
they did experiments
where they prevented
that evolution,
or they prevented-- they reduced
the heterogeneity in the prey
population.
And then they were able
to show that those two
features disappeared.
So, I think it's really
a beautiful example
of the interplay that
we always hope for,
which is that you do
theoretically motivated
experiments, and experimentally
motivated theory computation.
Ideally, you go back and forth.
And together, you
can really learn
more than you would
ever be able to do just
by doing one or the other.
We're also going to
try to say something
about the dynamics of
populations in space.
So, just like these
spatial patterns
that we talked about before,
in the context of maybe gene
networks, there
are also dynamics
of populations in space.
For example, when populations
expand into new territory,
what does that mean about
the evolutionary process?
Once again, some
very nice experiments
have been done over
the last decade
to try to eliminate
this process.
And in particular, one of
the things that was found
is that this process
of genetic drift,
the role of randomness in
the evolutionary process,
is somehow strongly enhanced
in many of these experimenting
populations.
Because somehow the
effective population size
that quantifies maybe
the strength of noise
is somehow enhanced.
Because it's not the
entire population matters.
It's just the
population at the front
of this expanding population
that is somehow relevant.
So, we'll explore how
these ideas play out.
And so, towards the
end of the class,
we'll try to think about some
real ecological phenomena.
In particular,
we're going to have
one lecture where we talk about
tipping points in populations.
It's a theme that my
group, for example,
has been very excited
about recently.
So, this here is data from
the Newfoundland cod fishery.
And it's an example of how
many natural populations can
actually collapse suddenly
and catastrophically
in response to deteriorating
environmental conditions.
Now, what's plotted
here-- this is essentially
the number of fish that are
caught as a function of time.
And you may not be able to read
this, but over on the left,
this is 1850, and
this the modern day.
So, this was a very productive
fishery for hundreds of years
and, actually, even for
hundreds of years before this.
However, in the '60s and '70s,
improved fishing technology
led to a dramatic increase
in the number of fish
that were caught here.
And that increase in fishing
led, in the early '90s,
to a catastrophic collapse
of that population.
Similar things have
occurred, for example,
in the sardine
fishery off the coast
of Monterey, and many
other populations.
So, the question here is, how
can we understand these tipping
points in populations?
And this is a case
where some of the ideas
we studied early in
the semester-- so,
these cases of interactions--
can lead to sudden transitions.
And for example, this
early example of a toggle
switch that we talked
about at the beginning--
so, this case where, if
you have interactions
within the population, it can
lead to alternative states.
And it's the same
basic dynamic here.
If you have interactions
within the population,
then you can get
alternative states--
maybe healthy and dead,
or extinct, locally.
So, you can imagine if you
have these alternative states
due to interactions
within the population,
and if you start out
in this healthy state,
and you start pushing it, then
it's going to-- the feedback
loops there will
maintain a state
where it's alive, healthy.
And then all of a
sudden, when it's not
able to counteract this
deteriorating environment, all
of a sudden it's going
to switch and maybe
collapse in this fishery.
So, these sorts
of ideas have been
used to both try to understand
why it is that populations
might experience tipping points,
but also to get some guidance
about ways that we can
anticipate that these tipping
points are approaching?
For example, in my group, we've
been excited about this idea
that there are predictions
that the fluctuations
of the population
should be different
when a population is approaching
one of these tipping points.
And, at least in
the laboratory, we
were actually able to measure
a change in the fluctuations
before a collapse.
And this is saying that, in
principle, there are maybe
universal signatures
of populations
and other complex systems before
one of these tipping points.
Now, in the last
lecture, we're going
to go maybe to the
largest scale to think
about whole ecosystems.
And this is, by its nature,
I'd say, less experimental
than the rest of the
semester in that,
in this case, we're trying
to understand questions like,
what is it that determines the
abundance of different tree
species on Barro
Colorado Island?
So, it's an island in
Panama where they go
and they just count every
tree within some region.
They'd say, this is this
country, this is that country.
They count thousands
and thousands of trees.
The question there
is-- some species
are more common than others.
And we want to know why.
It seems like a simple question.
And the way that we
normally think about this
is if it's more
common, then maybe it's
because it's better adapted
to that environment.
And I think that, often,
that's the right answer.
But there's been an interesting
movement within ecology
recently where it's been pointed
out that many of the patterns
that people have observed in
terms of this relative species
abundance-- how abundant
some species are as compared
to others-- that many
of those patterns
can actually be explained
by a purely neutral model.
I.e.
This is a model in which you
assume that all of the species
are the same.
So, this tree is just
the same as that tree
in terms of-- no tree is
better than any other tree.
But just because of the
stochastic dynamics,
random birth death
processes, you
can recover patterns that look
an awful lot like the patterns
are observed in nature.
So, you can interpret
this is in multiple ways.
But, of course, one way
that we should always
be thinking about
these things is
that if you observe-- we want
to collect quantitative data.
We should do that.
But there's always a
temptation that if you collect
quantitative data, and
then you write down
a model that is
consistent with that data,
we often take that
as strong evidence
that the assumptions of
our model are correct.
Even though we know
that's not the way we're
supposed to do science,
somehow it's just really easy
to fall into this trap.
And I think that this particular
example of this neutral theory
of ecology is a very
concrete example of how
different models that make
wildly different assumptions
about the underlying
dynamics-- they
can all look the
same once you look
at a particular kind of pattern.
And so, it's a nice
cautionary tale saying,
what is it that you can learn
about the dynamics of a system
or of a process based on a
particular kind of data set.
And then, after this, we will
just have that final exam.
That's going to be that
week of 15 to 19, I believe.
So, once again, do not book
your tickets before then.